hello the reject nation um Greg out I
can't do this right now
no I'm his bastard son Shawn we're gonna
watch these is the official trailer it
is the official trailer holy kiss balls
no more beer ads before we hop into this
I would like to say a special thank you
to each and every one of you has been
following us over at our patreon page as
yes we are planning on covering Game of
Thrones for season seven we did have
quite a few videos blocked worldwide but
we are still planning on doing reaction
highlights for Game of Thrones over at
our patreon page at minimum if they
can't get up on YouTube but for sure
there will be reactions stream alongs
over there and we also do TV show
reaction stream along for many shows
right now that includes my hero academia
finish all have attack on Titan Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood one punch
man
Gotham jaws now most of Riverdale
haunting at Hill House and supernatural
and we do reaction highlights for one
punch man my hero academia supernatural
hero now John's doing them for Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood guys would
mean a lot if you could follow us over
at our patreon page and want to thank
everyone who's been a part of there for
a while now you've helped us had a
really successful year 2018 so let's
kick some more ass with Game of Thrones
and April rolls around yo
she
[Laughter]
[Music]
doesn't die
-
well yeah who's Jamie I think why mall
you're pregnant
why not marry Cersei
you feel that increase production budget
oh my god oh man that last shot of them
all just at the line up there oh this is
cool this is really cool it's gonna
disappoint everyone no one's gonna be
happy with the way the show ends you're
all gonna be upset you don't think it's
gonna be the best thing in the world
it's gonna suck I'm not gonna lie I'm
gonna need a watch like at least two
Game of Thrones season like recaps
because it's been it's been a long time
it's been a long time forgetting certain
plot details of certain elements of
course remember how the whole like last
couple episodes went down because I was
so impactful and had a great cliffhanger
at the end this is like a very games of
Thrones kind of trailer where everyone's
preparing for battle it seems like Jamie
King is for sure Jamie King that's what
I called him Jamie King's called him
Jamie King yeah she's great what's her
name the Kings
what a lucky actor she is I feel like
they're playing restraint because they
know that we know that this is supposed
to be only like one and a half episodes
yeah I know there are nine hours like
most of what I got out of this trailer
just like here's a bunch of your
favorite characters they're all verified
to be back here are some Game of Thrones
type settings and now we're all going to
bask in the tension and the approach to
battle I mean at the beginning Arya is
my theory as she's running away from the
release date of new music please don't
put it out don't worry knows what its
gonna be anymore I don't want this to
hurt my legacy
they do cut back to that image really
quick if you like really slow this down
they're things I'm noticing now as I'm
talking where you do see REO like
fighting a bunch of something there's a
lot of like going around but I can't
tell
or what's going on people are bad White
Walkers you know for sure one of these
shots of Daenerys there's that one
shower Daenerys is walking up to Johnson
now one of these moments is when they
learn the truth yeah that'll be fun
that'll be a fun detail for everybody in
the season I want a real contain bottle
episode of them just bantering with each
other like it's discussing whether or
not they should still being you know I
think we can make this work brother and
sister like directly relate arms are
different now I'm gonna change it soon
this would be frowned upon with an
average tea imagine we got [ __ ]
dragons I don't think they showed us the
night king in this trailer because the
CGI's not done on him my king comes in
genie I watched a video recently where
somebody pointed out that like like for
half the show White Walkers do not fare
well against water but when they need to
bring a dragon out from underneath
freezing water they're great as oh yeah
all know that the production budget for
this has been drastically increased cuz
they're essentially bringing like a damn
movie to television for this one even
though you didn't get like a whole lot
of battle sequences you did get a lot of
look at the scope of the production as I
of what looks like real extras are on
set even the Dragons look much better
you know a lot of times for like the
dragon effects the best way to make them
look more real was put them and sort of
nighttime lighting yeah there's that
smoke or whatever yeah yeah it's that
way a big blending coat darker
cinematography looks were realistic but
there is that one shot where Daenerys
and Jon Snow are walking up to them and
there's like a pile of like a bunch
Subang devoured bodies or whatever
there's a lot of skeletal muscle parts
and you look at the Dragons there
right that's like Dragonheart I wonder
if maybe that was a conscious decision
or something's there's some action in
this trailer but I feel like one of the
main gripes people had about the last
season was that it'd be kind of became
like an action movie instead of like
Game of Thrones I wonder if maybe they
led with the fact that we know there's
gonna be a lot of pretty spectacular
action I would imagine so they're mostly
ramping up the stakes and the characters
and kind of bringing it back to that
well it's earned it they're teasing that
final battle where they're fighting the
night king at what looks like 1 a.m.
long as though each I feel like that
it's the worst time to 5 you got you you
want to fight the night walkers when
there's like you know enough light
illumination coming from the moon or you
can still sort of make out who everyone
is they're at a very big disadvantage if
that's the case it looks so dark on his
own turf yeah yeah we'll go we'll go
when it's like so dark maybe maybe
that's the thing is maybe the the armies
of you know the White Walkers is I can't
show up during the day and that's the
only time they can fight the white guys
we could coordinate if we're gonna have
this war we have to do it nice Oh what I
wanted to say to you is it looks like
Jaime Lannister had really fighting the
good fight really turn around especially
because he's like I fight for the lives
if you can fight for the living in yeah
yeah and I think I saw hiccup in this
trailer and the life here this is great
oh yeah definitely I mean this is all
when they move out of Berk it's gonna be
crazy crazy guys alright guys well this
is a stupid question are you excited for
Game of Thrones Season 8 what is a
theory you have that you think is so
crazy that no one believes you want but
you really have a hunch oh that it will
actually happen mine is that Tyrion will
grow two inches taller ooh
mine is that Jamie is gonna grow a foot
where his hand used to be ooh
because how interesting could that be
totally changed things are really
different and I like to have a patron
the day shadow a woman who has been a
part of our page front page for a long
time she doesn't ask for much but months
ago she said if there's a game of
Thrones trailer
I want a shout out on the Game of
Thrones trailer I'm of course talking
about the lady start of our channel that
is Rosa and her awesome daughter
Cassandra and also just those two forget
the other kids named Cassandra the main
ones who love us
Rosa we're gonna see you at the
free-for-all and you actually you know I
allow a lot of our patrons have
discovered us through our YouTube
channel some on movie fights but Rosa
discovered us because of John on the
Schmo down and that was at the first
free-for-all was so Rosa you best
believe John is gonna pleasure you in
front of the whole crowd it's the
opening gonna get banned from Schroeder
it's my entrance you'll join me wheeled
out doing rose up live on live on stage
the airport and he's gonna be answering
questions well satisfied I'm so sorry
that I shouted out your daughter very
disturbing yeah but don't worry she'll
be someplace entirely different from
this doing something completely
innocuous
don't let her watch this video nope love
you Rosa can't wait to see you in a
couple weeks guys you can subscribe the
reject nation click that notification
Bell check us out on patreon find out
where you know what